on dit souvent que la plupart des
psychopathes le sont devenus suite à une
mauvaise éducation ou un mauvais
traitement pendant leur enfance et moi
je pensais vrai je pense que toutes les
grandes catastrophes dans le monde sont
en réalité la faute des parents et ça
peut aller très vite une petite phrase
comme ça pendant l'enfance
par exemple
maman
j'ai encore perdu aux échecs
ah mais je te l'ai déjà dit où ça marche
les deux tours il faut toujours prendre
les deux tours
je vous en fait une plus cool pour vous
détendre
papa papa
quand je serai grand je veux être
chanteur
ah oui c'est très bien mais ici c'est
maman mon petit Gilbert
[Applaudissements]
pendant que
c'est juste comme ça
maman j'en ai plein
maman j'ai déjà fait toutes les pistes
vertes aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on peut
faire une piste noire
non marine les Noirs c'est dangereux
quand tu seras grande
fais attention à ce qu'on dit aux
enfants
maman maman j'ai fini de monter la
grande étagère dans le salon
c'est très bien Marc maintenant tu peux
monter les deux petites qui sont dans la
cave
[Applaudissements]
en Belgique elle marche beaucoup moins
bien
[Musique]
la dernière maman maman pourquoi je suis
maman maman pourquoi je suis
maman maman Manu je suis pas ta mère je
suis ta femme alors tu arrêtes
maintenant
[Applaudissements]